bakugo squirk is evolving and it might
even be fusing with one for all we just
recently found out that when bakugo
seemingly died during his battle against
shigaraki he did really die physically
his heart and other organs straight up
stopped functioning edshot managed to
use his special technique to repair
bakugo's internal organs but even after
he repaired them physically they still
weren't working bakugo's heart still
wasn't beating then bakugo's Quirk
seemed to act on its own and one of his
sweat spheres exploded inside his
bloodstream and shocked his heart and
other organs back to life where have we
seen this kind of thing before one for
all also has the ability to act on its
own to protect its user like when it
helped Deku overcome shinso's mind
control either bakugo squirk is evolving
and becoming sentient or bakugo squirk
is merging with one for all after bakugo
temporarily had a chance to use it in
the second mha movie for more info on
this click the related video right now
and subscribe to anime uproar for more
mha content